oder eine reihe an penissen auf dem
rücken wie einstiegen
hallo mein name bukarest will kommen
heute zu einem neuen video mir
vielleicht schon nicht heute sondern
könnte ist letztlich ein bisschen
erkennen max und ich machen heute
nämlich einen know your best friends tag
gibt es überhaupt den namen auf jeden
fall großen dienstag erwartete
rundschreiben verlinkt ab und zu bilder
auf denen sprüche stehen wie
beispielsweise hey da steht nirgendwo
halo knapp jedes bild wird steht
nirgendwo hält würde dein aller besser
folge das internet für ein ganzes jahr
aufgeben oder seine browser history also
seinen internet verlauf öffentlich
machen so internet verläufe browser
vertreten sind ja so eine sache die
gehen angst nicht viele leute waren vor
allen dingen wie luca immer auf alles
klar aber also ich glaube persönlich ist
du würdest er deine browser history
publik machen einen youtube ohne
internet keine videos machen und dann
ist es lieber dass ein bisschen peinlich
ist weil du ja irgendwie schon mal
bestimmt in deinem leben im internet
aufgerufen hat niemals ich war mal auf
dem kanal von crown praxis tatsächlich
große scheibe als auflösung von dieser
nummer muss ich mir wirklich leider
sagen dass du recht hast gewusst
pa köln würde dein allerbester freund
lieber einen schwanz für 50.000 dollar
rutschen oder 1000 euro für jeden
schwanz bekommen den er lust was
gefunden
mehr als 50 in italien nutzen will
wer hat den 50.000 euro dafür eilen
klinik bekommen würde ich könnte das
natürlich schon zutrauen aber ich war
körperlich wirklich nehmen eur 1 direkt
50.000 euro gar nicht so einfach wie du
schreibst einfach so lala oder würde
dein blieb es eher eine einmalige
zahlung von 100.000 dollar erhalten oder
eine kreditkarte auch der immer 25
dollar sind haben ich glaube tatsächlich
dass du die ewigkeit 25 gerade nehmen
würde weil könnt ihr jeden tag kostenlos
essen bestellen und bei 100000 das geld
irgendwann direkt auf braucht aber
lieber kleine summen zur verfügung als
einer von fünf minuten erhöhten entweder
ich habe direkt nach 5 20 euro hinter
pferde 23 euro kostet wäre perfekt
gewesen mich jeden tag kämpfen zu
bestellen deswegen ja richtig gehört
würde dein bester freund lieber den
ironman guthaben oder das ganze geld von
ihrem bett wäre schon gut in seiner
hässlichkeit müssen abdecken mensch ein
dem geld das ich nicht wirklich nicht
deswegen würde ich sagen ich glaube über
den mut um von überall geld sind schon
fertig in deinem leben
ich weiß nicht wie viel geld der ton in
der serie hat weil er hat halt unmengen
geld ich würde trotzdem sagen eure band
hilfrich ehrlich ja absolut verständlich
nicht lange daten von geldkarten
entwickeln ermöglichen anzug
ich glaube das kann man nicht in geld
aufwiegen wenn sowas wirklich geben
würde würde sein wie rap lieber auge
haben die alles filmen können oder ohren
haben die alles aufnehmen können
logischerweise sollten beide bsv entrup
anfängern vor sich alles keine könnte
was man hört oder aber sie ich
persönlich glaube aber dass die augen
nehmen würdest du alles filmen können
weil einfach so verrückt wird so was man
teilweise dafür gibt wieder szenen die
sich abstimmung eingebracht hätte ich
das mal ganz gefallen wäre hätte er ich
das auch generell augen sind auch
einfach eine perfekte kamera kann man
sieht halt einfach alles seine augen
seien gleich aussage des jahres meine
damen und herren bitte schreibt erstmals
als total und in die kommentare weil man
sieht halt einfach alles mit seinen
augen also während luca weg ist wenn ich
mal sagen
[Musik]
blogs recht ich würde wirklich die augen
nehmen weil es halt wirklich auch die
kinder auf wenn man die frage kann schon
mal im video wenn man die wahl hätte
zwischen traub sein oder also dass man
nicht hören kann oder als nicht sehen
kann würde ich auf jeden fall taugt sein
nehmen weil du sieht einfach noch so
viel wie du hast schon gedacht dass mit
seinem zitat weil man sieht halt einfach
alles mit seinen trainer würde sein
allerbester freund lieber etwas von der
vergangenheit wieder witzeln dafür etwas
ort der zukunft verlieren oder etwas
wissen was in der zukunft passieren wird
aber etwas sehr sehr wichtiges von der
vergangenheit vergessen also das erste
ist quasi das duo etwas aus der
vergangenheit hat irgendwie vergessen
hat die kraft stehen irgendwann bereuen
sich überhaupt nicht erinnern kann ist
allgemein dass du das wieder ändern kann
fordert dass etwas von der zukunft aus
der zukunft weiß dass er in wirklichkeit
auf der vergangenheit allerdings
verliert also ich würde ich ehrlich
gesagt sagen glaube ich dass du lieber
etwas auf der zukunft wissen willst ich
weiß nicht ob man besser aussuchen darf
als ob man jetzt wissen darf wie man
stirbt oder so aber ich denke wirklich
dazu erst aus der zukunft finden möchte
und dafür riskiert etwas wichtige worte
berger hat vergisst als das erste mal
falsch liegt nicht an irgendwelche
richtig wichtigen erinnern
keine ahnung wie man irgendwann fragt ob
man ihn heiraten möchte oder so wichtige
kann man vergessen und dafür was
einzutauschen von dem momentan weist das
system würde an sich ist das eigentlich
wurscht wer vergisst was man vergessen
deshalb ist die antwort eigentlich für
die fans würden bfr opfer über wenn
damon also beim niesen quasi auf sein
date runde verein oder laut fuchs
während er mit ihr bei dem date ich
kenne ihn wissen luca würde wert militär
zu neigen laut wussten meine erfahrung
da wirst du auch er macht ihr gewicht zu
halten laut forster kann so hey das ist
einfach noch menschlich aber jemand
einfach ins gewicht braucht man etwas
mitnehmen zu tun so dass andere
natürlich auch aber aufgeben wäre hätte
dein bester freund er eine vagina
orchesters tieren eine reihe an penissen
auf dem rücken wie einstieg
das ist wirklich super info also ich
würde mir dieser eine vagina er gesagt
weil lieber eine vagina als fünfte auf
dem rücken alter ermöglichen über seine
mütze immer würden allerbester freund
lieber sein erstes kind mit 19 jahren
haben oder sein erstes kind mit 45
jahren haben falträder das wird sich
nicht mehr selbst die antwort war
wirklich schrieben 45 ist durchaus
relativ hohes alter und kinder zu
kriegen verantwortung und finanzen und
sowas einfach deutlich angemessener noch
im hohen alter vater zu werden weil
einfach selbst reifer wissen und er das
ist für dein kind der glaube ich eher
mit 45 nein ich hätte wirklich gesagt 19
schlichtweg aus dem grund weil ich
meinem kind das ich einfach deutschland
mehr bin ich 40 bin mein kind ist dann
sollte ich dann wäre man wenn mein vater
jetzt gerade 65 wäre obwohl das ist
eigentlich gar nicht so eine große
entscheidung sagen echt nicht so
krawallig sind 19 vertrag bis mitten ins
studium und sonstige franken
ich glaube du hast doch recht darüber
hab ich gar nicht in allerbester freund
er 50 prozent des körpers komplett
verbranntem verbrennungen verdient oder
100 komplett tätowiert
an der stelle muss ich sagen dass sie
glaube ich mehr oder weniger ein
bisschen feiern würde die zahlen nie ein
selber stechen lassen aber verbrennungen
natürlich mit schmerzen verbunden 100
prozent reduziert haben allerdings
verfügte sehr sehr hohe kosten weg laser
lassen natürlich auch nicht gut die haut
ich werde 100 prozent richtig also
definitiv also entweder du bist
komplettiert oder du hast prozent
verbracht und wenn ich schon konkret
wird wäre hätte ich längst keines mehr
ja sagen wir kennen uns ziemlich gut
oder reserviert aufwachen dabei waren
wie und wirklichen wahrscheinlich nie
passieren werden so wann kommt ihr an
und gibt ihr 50.000 euro wenn du also
das wird denke ich nie passiert das auch
irgendwie sind unangebracht trotzdem
muss nicht sagen bei denen werden die
wirklich relevant haben
haben wir uns eigentlich ganz punkte
kann krieg heute groß schreiben die
neueste ergangen sonst bin ich dann hast
du jetzt ihr vom video wenn es euch
gefallen hat auch gerne online gewesen
wenn er darauf könnt ihr kostenlos main
kanal abonnieren verfasst haben sich
keine videos mehr doch mein stock
eingeblendet und hier unten andere video
da solltet ihr unbedingt drauf legen das
ist megageil
sechs paare egal